[Music]
people were talking about how realistic
gravity is and i just had to ask you
um
did you seen the movie i've seen it yep
did you feel it was a fairly realistic
portrayal of what it's like in space uh
there were parts of it that were fairly
realistic yes right actually the visuals
in that were as better than any space
movie ever made it's just
visually just like being out on a
spacewalk it's beautiful and then i was
curious because there's a scene that uh
really uh got a lot of people's
attention where she uh senator bullock
takes off her space suit and you see her
dressed this way in space
i love that scene and i i think she but
i was curious is that something is that
a way that people dress do they take off
their spacesuits in space and float
around like that or is that a hollywood
convention i've done two uh two space
walks and inside our spacesuit we're
wearing uh this like a halloween costume
which is a liquid cooling garment and
we're wearing
like depends underneath big boy kind of
pull up diapers underneath and and you
come out you've been sweating in there
for eight hours
uh your hair looks like rat fur we we do
not look like a an underwear bottle when
we come up i think they made the right
call in the movie though thanks
sandra sandra bullock like take off her
suit revealing giant depends
rats
lots of rat fur on her head
they'd be like hey man it's real
deal with it